unless you are not paying attention or
willingly ignorant at this point as I
mentioned in the last segment you have
to believe that Donald Trump has either
explicitly or implicitly made it known
that he will offer pardons
to people who remain loyal to him in the
Trump Russia investigation and I want to
go through with you what we know at this
point okay number one there are what are
called joint defense agreements mostly
informal although possibly formal in
some cases where Donald Trump's personal
legal team is working with the legal
teams of Paul Manafort and Jerome Corsi
and others meaning that Donald Trump's
legal team knows exactly what Robert
Muller is doing what Robert Muller is
asking where Robert Muller is probing
that's number one number two Donald
Trump's indicted campaign manager Paul
Manafort made an agreement with special
prosecutor Robert Muller where he would
receive a reduced sentence reduced
punishment fewer charges there was a
deal made whatever but in exchange for
that Paul Manafort had to tell them the
truth
and help them fry bigger fish so to
speak and we learned this week that Paul
Manafort still lied okay mana four made
a deal to cooperate and then broke that
deal by lying why would anyone do that
unless they were number one scared to
death of telling the truth or number two
they knew or suspected or surmised that
they should keep their mouth shut
and that a pardon would eventually get
them out of trouble that's Paul Manafort
then number three we get to this
horrible character a hero of the birther
movement
his name's Jerome Corsi and last night
re Melbourne had a really interesting
interview with jerome corsi on MSNBC and
i encourage you to watch the entire
interview it's about 20 minutes Corsi
spent those 20 minutes talking about how
he's simply telling the truth
he's heroically rejecting a plea deal
with Robert Muller because it would have
required him to say things that aren't
true he debated the definition of a lie
with our with our email BER
and then the topic of Pardons come up
not because our email Burress about it
but because your own course he brings it
up unprovoked and it gets really awkward
but it is very very illuminating for
what we're talking about today you know
and I'm not counting on Donald Trump for
anything including a pardon like that's
not the basis on which I made my
decision I don't know why are you
bringing up a part in everybody you were
talking about it before everybody I
didn't ask you about the department
you're bringing up a part I'm bringing
it up because I want to make it clear
that I don't expect one I'm not asking
for one and I'm making my decision
completely on the basis that I know off
to face trial if they do indict me I
understand consequences on megohm I
understand you sir I understand you face
there I understand that and I understand
that would you accept a part ABB's no
except a pardon is hypothetical as a
whole conversation you brought up a
hypothetical market conversation give me
a hypothetical answer I don't get let's
not it be offered and I'll tell you what
I'll do at that time
so people listening or may draw the
inference that you actually are right
now auditioning for a part and when you
end that statement by saying let it be
offered you know I really I took that
mind you asking me not to tell you what
people who are listening think I don't
know what they're thinking but you're
not asking for a pardon is your is I'm
not asking for a part understood and I'm
not anticipating a part do you
understand why people don't believe you
yes of course I've had this problem all
my life fascinating interview I
encourage you to watch the entire thing
which I did last night but like re Mel
burr I also don't believe that pardons
haven't at least been intimated during
the last several months then after all
of this we learned that Roger stone 1/3
close Trump operative who's very wrapped
up in all of this and is possibly
getting indicted himself Roger stone
spoke to Trump on the phone the day
after he received information that
WikiLeaks email dumps were coming
someone who was also in Roger stones
case in touch with jerome corsi someone
who learned from jerome horseys
allegedly rejected plea agreement that
he is a central part of this and
investigation further implicating Trump
in at minimum knowing about what was
going on with the WikiLeaks email dumps
coinciding again with Donald Trump's
public statements and tweets about
documents expected to be released by
WikiLeaks in advance so these guys Pat
are all in touch they all know what's
going on they're all communicating with
Trump about their defenses and this is
yet another possible constitutional
crisis which we'll get to in a second do
you believe that these guys have no idea
whether Trump will pardon them or do you
think they suspect they certainly are
auditioning for pardons I think and
that's probably the best path forward
for all of them but it is incredibly
risky I think like if Paul Manafort
accepts a plea deal from the Muller
probe and he eventually turns on it and
then it you find out that Trump can't
pardon him for one reason or another
because it's challenged in court or
because he's no longer president well
then Paul Manafort is gonna end up
getting the maximum sentence and
probably go to prison for the rest of
his life well there's another possible
constitutional crisis here and it's not
just the pre-emptive pardon that is a
possibility with presidents of the
United States you hear time and again
this phrase Pat that the pardon power of
the president is absolute meaning
doesn't matter whether the pardon was
issued because Trump felt someone was
unfairly prosecuted or because they
agreed not to spill the beans on Trump
that it just doesn't matter because the
president's pardon power is absolute
that's not exactly true
I mean imagine a situation where someone
shows up at the Oval Office with a bag
of money and says here's a bag of money
in exchange for a pardon according to
legal experts that would be over the
line it would change the idea of an
absolute pardon power so there is that
line and it's going to be up to courts
as you're suggesting to figure out sort
of where that line is and whether it's
been crossed and ultimately you know the
downside is that Trump's supreme court
of extremists and serial accused sexual
assaulters is going to adjudicate that
which isn't great but if you're thinking
about this a great question is whether
legally for knowledge or intimation of
future part
is illegal and it might be because any
suggestion that a pardon might be in
someone's future if they lie or if they
withhold information from federal
investigators that which would be a
hallmark of Trump's behavior in Trump
Russia is an obstructive action it is a
form of obstruction of justice it's
arguably also witness tampering
right because the possibility of a
pardon is being used to influence the
testimony that somebody gives that by
definition is witness tampering so it's
another day it's another two to three
scandals what do you think do future
pardons explain this bizarre behavior of
Paul Manafort and Jerome Corsi and
increasingly Roger stone let me know I'm
on Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
twitter at david pakman show one of
today's sponsors is privacy dot-com
slash Pakman this is a free service that
I've actually been using myself for a
while now and I love it
you just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
coms mobile app or browser extension for
Firefox and Chrome and what that does is
allow you to instantly create virtual
credit cards that are linked to your
bank account so that you're not actually
putting your real debit card number on
the Internet and you use these virtual
credit card numbers to buy things online
and with one click of a button you have
the ability to create multiple virtual
cards delete cards freeze and unfreeze
cards you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted
and in some situations you can earn 5%
cash back on your purchases it's all
completely free all you have to do is
click the link under this video to get
started and for a limited time everybody
in our audience who signs up gets $5.00
towards your first purchase when you
sign up using that link below